What we're going to do next, is we're going to show our
designs to three other people, and find out how, we
as designers, can improve them. How do we make it
simpler? How can we increase the discoverability? And, what are the
cues for feedback, and how do we make those stronger?
For a few tips, see the project brief, on how to
do an effective feedback session with users. Now let's watch
Clifton, as he shows his designs to Kathleen, a potential user.
Notice how he interacts with Kathleen, and
in particular, notice how he asks her questions.
>> So Kathleen, imagine you have this new product, this digital wallet,
that you kind of you can trade times with other people. So you start off
here. And tell me what you see, and what you would like to do?
>> So, it looks
like I have,
a bank and my balance right now is three hours, and 10 minutes.
>> Okay, so what, what would you do here?
>> I would probably type in, you know, whatever
I'm looking for, knowing what that I have my balance
and start, start looking for you know, a person to
help me. Trade, or do whatever I'm looking to do.
>> Mm, okay. So let's assume you
tap on this you go to this screen.
>> I'm going to say that I'm looking for somebody to clean my
house so that I have a, an idea to, to keep going with.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And my, my, yeah. And so now I
think I would see that these are all the people
who are near me and and what costs they have.
Looks like the red and the green. Red would be,
maybe, by myself. I like that it is. Actually, something that I think it
would be nice is if we actually started with the green and it showed me
the things that I could afford first,
rather than the things I can't afford because
that, that seems a little snubbing. Like, hey, look at this, you can't have it.